this is a production of Cornell
University trip down memory lane for me
I actually was walking through the
conservatory and enjoying you know the
walk and everything and noticing all the
different changes different buildings
everything and and it's different as it
is it's still home like I come back and
I'd say wow I remember studying those
plants the wee hours and doing the same
thing over and over again and it's still
there because it's still those
fundamentals and I just I'm really
enjoying being back so thank you all for
having me so the party side of
horticulture I figured hey you know
every horticulturist needs a little
party side and why not talk about that
I've been fortunate enough to learn but
I've been able to bring this side into
it combine it with the art side the core
side everything and Here I am 20 years
later in a degree that really was
started here in these rooms where I
studied plants and and everything about
it just to sort of kind of give you the
quick background of where I came from so
I grabbed an orchard Park New York
little suburb where's your Park yeah
everybody's always one who are you from
anyway um that's my hometown I you know
grew up there so it's you know a little
bit of Tundra as we all know New York
can be how did I get my influences where
how did I ever get into this so yes
gardening is my passion it was something
I did literally when I was 5 or 6 years
old I had that little 8 foot square
garden that you know your parents always
build for you but I had the benefit of
having a grandfather Pennsylvania Dutch
and bringing manure up in his trunk to
enhance my garden so I was like ok first
clue that there's something more than
just digging in the dirt
second of all walking around with my
parents so both my parents were art
teachers in my school district so they
taught me the appreciation of art and
and earth and everything and my father
and I would little
walk around his backyard and just adore
little details so he looked more in the
woods so it was not really a lawn that
he would have so the moss would grow in
his backyard and we would just and not
be upset that we didn't have a lawn so
we made the best of it and we called it
the tuna tournament and we would say
tuna cans into the moss and we made a
golf course in our backyard like make
the best of every noticing like little
things like the lichen on the trees and
and and all that stuff that is just
nature eat red is finest right um you
know I also look back with my uncle was
I mean he was he was a college professor
of English and whatever but really just
got into hobby plan so the gingko tree
in the middle of downtown Buffalo in a
little town house back yard in this
beautiful little garden that led up to
this amazing gingko tree and they're
like wow you know when you see different
things it really starts to open your
eyes that okay yeah they're not just
like the typical maples that you see
around or whatever you say oh my gosh
there's something more to to all this
and you know this is all hindsight that
I'm looking at so of course I get to
senior year in high school what am I
gonna do with my life well hey we're
gonna culture Cornell let's go applied
got in and I actually stuck with floor
culture and ornamental horticulture all
four years it's rare but I did and your
year came around I wasn't sure what to
do have a lot of interest you know I
like landscape architecture I
appreciated the art side of horticulture
and I'll back up because there was a
professor here I believe it professor
Fisher dr. Fisher that was here my
freshman year but I never took his class
who concentrated on the floral culture
and the floral arts and whatnot I never
took a plural class in my life come
around senior year they had stuff an
award for him for design students in
horticulture and I actually won that so
I feel like okay something more to this
right
the drear Ward was another thing that I
applied to I I said jeez you know you're
about to graduate Ivy League school
flora culture ornamental horticulture
and yet I never took the forestry class
I know where to culture I knew names of
plants into everything what can I do to
further my Ivy League education well she
I'm gonna go to Europe I'm gonna start
and some of the best floral designers
around there and see what they have to
say so I started in London and I would
say what do you think it's the best
place to go to what who should I go
study with like oh my gosh no Nicky Bob
Paris sunny and speak to Christian tour
- nope you should go to Copenhagen those
so every couple weeks or months or
something that I pack up my bags and I
just I intern I learned I immerse myself
in this amazing business of flora
culture and it's such a serious thing
over there I know here we're like Oh
flowers it's cute yeah it's a little
subculture but it is people go and
basically the essential master's degree
to be a florist over there I mean it's
very serious and I was lucky enough to
be with a bunch of companies that did
events that really just showed every
aspect of it I mean just bringing the
whole thing to life and taking it very
seriously and and just big industry so
you know I worked I worked all these
different places and I came back
comparable as well you know work permits
weren't coming in from overseas and
everything so I finally said okay I'll
start in New York City it's why not and
I did and with gusto
so I started with a bunch of different
companies that did very similar you know
concepts of party side of horticulture
they did events the arts of the party
everything like that that really just I
never really took seriously I guess I
always thought of florists being yeah
it's just florists I learned flowers you
know I'm never gonna make a lot of money
there's a whole other side of it that is
it's very true so I worked for a bunch
of people in the city I ended up meeting
my husband and he was from New Jersey
and he said you know I might come out to
New Jersey there's a bunch of people out
here who like flowers to it so very
welcome and you know Here I am nineteen
years later I've got two locations I've
got an amazing business on the right
feet and I love every day of it cuz I
love to tell people I just I have a
hobby and I get paid for it and I have a
lot of fun with it and all my my
employees do - we just it's all the time
so anyway I figured I would sort of go
through this
definitely I'm very open to questions
and everything I guess will props to it
afterwards and stuff like that so let me
just present this start with so I
figured here I was putting this
presentation together they are - the
party will force everybody things and
stuff like this
the Bucknell you know like gardens all
around and party party party well that's
what we want you to sort of kind of
thing that happens when we're pulling
off the party you know there's a lot
that goes behind but this I think is the
image oh she does parties you know she's
hanging out and everything cuz when I'm
done setting up I'm going home and
crashing flora culture obviously flora
culture and horticulture is so closely
related with flora culture obviously is
more related to flowers and there's a
huge industry it's a hundred billion
dollar industry people it is very much
at roofing in sense of growing managing
you know the greenhouses the shipping
the packing the moving the making of
flowers and the executing of events it's
there's so much to it um you know again
like I think everybody should dabble in
a little bit of everything related to
horticulture to get you to this point
flora culture it's it's definitely more
specialized but it's something that
really is just a very serious business I
know we were talking earlier today that
I mean there's people who try to grow
their own flowers I mean learning how to
pronunce produce that how to perfect it
and and get it I mean I love buying
dahlias from my local growers I love
buying the cherry blossoms from the
farmers down the street I but there's so
much that goes into it so and then the
other main part of what I see is the
decor so it's the art side obviously you
know I just put this definition I here
because I think as simple as it is it's
so true but you know the purpose of
decoration make the space more
aesthetically pleasing you know I mean
think about all the Stefan why would you
throw a party
why would you why do you even have
flowers in your house why is it that you
you wanted to it's the decor it's and
the decor is there because it really
wants to play into the human side of
life
you have flowers to cheer you up even if
it's just if it's one little arrangement
bad day all of a sudden you're like yes
I appreciate that
if you're doing an event a big wedding I
mean it's we're there to celebrate that
moment that marriage one moment in time
and plants just represent that you know
like stop and smell the roses everybody
talking about old school florists listen
there was a time and place for
everything florists you know back in the
day we didn't have internet you know all
that other's weight them is before my
time but you know so it was the local
yokel you know you you knew the
neighborhood florist was like no in the
grocery and they were there for all
those special occasions they have a
brick-and-mortar that worked back then
today it's a little different I know it
was there's still brick and mortars that
exist today and I think location really
plays into that and people do need a
place to go mind you I know so many
grocery stores have popped up and you
know I know we were speaking earlier
today about like oh gosh well how do you
feel the whole grocery store concept
selling flowers most people are like a
florist would be like oh hate it hate it
I'll tell you hon I love it
you know why it's introducing the fact
that flowers should be part of your life
you know you you know it's like Martha
Stewart started with that you know she
really would push it and be like oh
let's let's enjoy your garden pick your
garden put it on your table same thing
with like the supermarkets I want them
to have affordable flowers because if
it's just like ten tulips that you bring
home and you just say wow I had a really
rough week but you know what
life goes on this is a moment in time ah
breathe right so um the new school of
thought for florists yes there's still
retail florists like I still have people
to call and say hey you know need
personage for a prom or something like
that but the majority of people today
are working out of studios we don't need
to necessarily have a brick-and-mortar
store I mean if oh my gosh with the
Internet if you have an amazing website
if you have a great following if you
have all these you know connections
community I almost find that I'm more
enticing to a couple that's like oh my
gosh I found the greatest floral design
person she's off the beaten track I'll
I'll take you to where she is she's
behind this building in warehouse or
whatever it's sort of like finding a
that speakeasy kind of restaurant that's
an amazing Italian restaurant you didn't
know about you know it's finding that
great designer and your overhead goes
down dramatically so I'm just gonna take
that money and move it right over to my
advertising budget why do I need a
brick-and-mortar people are shopping
online all the time you better just stay
with the times I think that's probably
one of the challenges I see most
florists getting into is that they need
to separate themselves let them do the
markets have their flowers let event
designers and decor p-funk get into
their niche of being those people that
really do the events you're not gonna go
to Wegmans and all of a sudden say hey I
need this huge event and I need lighting
and linens and whatever they're like
whoa whoa whoa you know don't call us
but that's what we do we do a total
event decor flowers our forte so this
one the stems it was sort of I was
considering this like the stock of the
industry so you know obviously these are
some of the main things that I wanted to
really focus on when it comes to what's
important in this industry um let's talk
about where the flowers come from they
come from all over you know gone are the
days that everything was in the states I
mean New Jersey my gosh only four
percent now used to be huge I mean the
Madison New Jersey if anybody is anybody
from New Jersey by the way hey you
Madison New Jersey used to be this huge
like rose city they would call it I mean
it's still on their signs either um it's
not that way anymore
we know listen the world has changed
labor is crazy how much was it to build
that green house conservatory out there
you know it's I mean there's a lot that
you have to put into it to make it
affordable and I think I have found that
the American culture is not quite up to
that power of you know departing with
their money when it comes to luxury
quite yet so we're working on that so it
still cost is a huge factor where the
trend is now obviously is foreign
flowers that's not a bad thing it's you
know it's affordable I understand they
have a lot of beautiful coops set up and
stuff like that in some of these foreign
countries
you know I'm Colombian Ecuador whatever
and you know they support their
communities and I love how they're doing
it you know obviously they don't make as
much as what we're doing but it's
something that you know it's just good
people say oh isn't everything like a
Dutch flower we're what about Aalsmeer
and stuff like that well if anybody's
familiar with the whole floral clock and
and everything else Mir is just the
largest warehouse of where the majority
of flowers sort of kind of get filtered
through it's the buying auction so even
though in Aalsmeer you say oh I'm buying
Dutch flowers well they're coming from
New Zealand they're coming from Israel
they're coming from South Africa getting
filtered bought on this auction clock
and then dispersed so even though
they're coming from places like this
some of these might be considered Dutch
flowers so it's a little confusing
California obviously I love this focus
that you know we still have a good
majority of flower growers here I I have
seen more and more and I was talking
about this this morning to more and more
local growers the sustainability that
real organic trend of people just
knowing what their product is all about
and I think there's a play into what I'm
going to say a little bit in the future
here but with the education of people
knowing where their product comes from
and what goes into it and once they know
that they will pay for it because it's
the understanding so you know this is a
trend right now where we're at another
thing I wanted to just sort of kind of
note about the foreign stuff you know
couple my wholesalers I've been talking
to and just really like tell me your
secrets like what do you what do you
want to say to the industry if you could
and they said well you know you just
always have to be abreast of what's
going on so for example like a lot of
these truckers and and everything these
days have new restrictions that you know
god bless them this is great that they
have only so many hours that they can
work in the day and then they have to
take a rest listen I want the guy
driving a truck to have a rest too
I don't have to plow into my family car
or the guy driving the plane you know he
needs a break to every only breaks but
just logically seen about the impact in
the sense that well now these growers
probably have to pay twice as much to
have a second driver to get that yeah
that perishable item to somewhere in
time otherwise you're not going to get
your flowers or you're gonna get dead
flowers so it's now those are the
factors that start kind of increased the
cost of why some of these foreign things
are crazy so you might say well cheaper
to buy South American or something but
in all honesty by the time you just pay
the FedEx guy or you know maybe have
somebody go like your driver go up to
Vermont and pick up something you know
turn out to be the same and might
actually be a little bit fresher so
alright technology I know I touched upon
this a little bit before but really this
is so integral to what a surviving
floral designer needs I know I sort of
kind of crossover between florists and
event designers but I think how a floral
designer is going to survive is again
not necessarily having a
brick-and-mortar
anymore but having your best friends
these social media you know I know so
many different floors that have hired PR
companies basically to keep them going
they're working in their barns they're
working in their basements they're
working in warehouses and they it
doesn't matter and then they just have
to have their image consultants out
there
to really show people yes I still do
amazing work even though I'm not
foolishly spending my money on on the
Main Street USA you know I think my
laptop some days like when I'm working
remotely like even this morning I it was
my computer my my phone and I was
ordering flowers for the rest of the
week in fact I was finishing my
Valentines Day order it was just it's so
easy to do things now that if you don't
keep up with times you're not gonna
survive floral design has evolved into
events and it's just you've got to keep
going with this Instagram Pinterest
Facebook oh my goodness I even need to
explain to you guys you guys are
probably
and that generation it's so engrained in
you but it's something that wasn't
always there it's it's sort of
portfolios online I was saying to
somebody the other day like how people
my brides come to me and they say oh
well here's here's my Pinterest page let
me show you and that's before I even
pull out the portfolio of what I've done
I mean the world is so together now that
you can pull these images your ideas and
they used to in front of me and say well
I like this eye profile that and put it
into world world and then I present a
product of an event and and it comes
together and it's so easy you know
location location location okay so it's
still you probably do need to sort of
kind of focus on where you are I mean I
I would love to do events all the time
in the Bahamas or you know all these
other places and it is possible I know a
lot of people that are like event
planners that do stuff like that
but I think you still have to have a
little proximity to what you can
actually do you know this sort of kind
of comes in at location more than just
your physical space but you know where
you're buying flowers from I mean I love
to I love to buy local I love to tell
people you should use what's in season
you know you're in the Northeast you
should use flowers that are up here
happy to bring in tropicals or something
for your event but you know let's just
sort of kind of look at the scenario
where we are and everything and what's
cost-effective what's what's amazing and
and what's important it's sort of kind
of supporting your communities it's
supporting the fact that well you know
what I still need I need a driver I need
a flower cleaner I need a flower packer
I need somebody to even literally take
out the garbage these are all things
that are important that really just
support the community so your location
is key you know where I have my store in
New Jersey it's in the middle of New
Jersey in Bernardsville but I have some
studio in Hoboken and I have different
areas for different reasons I have a
greater wealth of floral designers that
I get from the city and from Hoboken
that you know sometimes they'll come out
to my other location but you have to
sort of kind of position yourself where
it's in the make sense and work
booming industry so one of the other
things I have found that most floral
designers and event people is the
education if any of you ever taken like
floral workshops has anybody done that
they are so prevalent and I have found
you know I've had my business now for 19
years so somewhere around 2007 2008 when
the economy was a little shaky I decided
to get into some floral workshops and
tell people that you know this is the
way to do it you want to save money when
you know the time you stink a little bit
let me teach you how to do arrangements
why don't you go into your art and look
to see what you have maybe you don't
have everything and then you supplement
it with a couple things that you go by a
florist or wherever but it was the
education and I found it was so
important it was so so key and when I
really first started it you know I would
have them all set up and beautiful
pretty and you know the girls will come
in the Louboutin shoes and yeah we're
gonna have fun and whatever and I found
out after a couple times I was like well
I'm lying a little bit is we all know
like you gotta dig in the dirt a little
bit right so the next several classes I
started to evolve into well I'm just
gonna bring in the boxes of flowers put
it on the counter I'm like okay let's go
to it I'm gonna teach you how to clean
the flowers condition them everything
because that is more than half the
battle I mean someday we're gonna write
a book about like all the conditioning
aspects of it but you know let me give
these people a little bit of
introduction and what goes into the fact
that you paying for this flower arranger
you're paying for this event and you use
that sticker shock but you're like oh
great but all these things play into it
so I do now it's a two-hour class you
know for the single classes and they
come in and they do all that they learn
how to you know the right water or you
do they put anything in the water to
they condition it whatever and it's
fantastic and every single class and I
have and I'm sure I'm not the only one
who can say this that there are people
who come in they make it they love it
they love it they have this
now that they know what to do but they
look me straight in the eye and they say
I will never doubt but I need to order
flowers from you because that is a lot
of work and I'm like yes you know it
same thing of like they might take a
class and say yes I'm gonna do this for
my daughter's baby shower you know we're
all here to learn and you're like that's
great but please don't do that let me
tell you that there's so much into it
because what if your flowers were coming
on that plane and that food order that
was going to be on the basement of KLM
it was a lot more important than your
flowers oh yeah that luxury item and it
got bumped and so now it's not coming
till tomorrow and that's the day you
should go get your hair done and your
nails done I would rather take out
stress for you and let me have you pay
me to take that stress off of me so
there's so anyway overlapping industries
I mean me I say Morton listen this world
is so tied in together everything needs
to overlap you need to sort of kind of
adapt and how can you make it survive a
hotel industry
I mean I'm constantly talking to people
in that industry because it's it's the
service industry more than half my
business is really service oriented I'm
I'm talking to people I'm profiling them
to like make an event make it make it a
decor that represents their personality
you know that just there's so much that
overlaps the hotel's the restaurant
business everything like that wedding
planners I think so often we get
confused with being a what a wedding
planner we are I think this division of
it is more just the event so I tell
people we do purely like anything and
everything to do with decor like I will
go into a bagram I will strip it
completely I can bring in you know all
these tables the linens the Chargers the
lighting the fabric everything and
basically change it change the entire
ambience with the core being the flowers
and that the flowers again being the
representation of what we're actually
there to celebrate so it's it's all just
sort of kind of blown up and wedding
planners again differentiate in the
sense that they're sort of kind of there
for the religious
to find more so like okay I'm gonna
coordinate when the band's here I'm
gonna coordinate
who's gonna show up when I'm gonna keep
that bride on on target what I do is
basically meet with the vet planners and
sometimes they will say the wedding
planner or whatever we'll say okay thank
god Laura's here now so just talk to
Laura about anything decor wise just let
her go and and you plan out everything
that you need to decor anything um this
one I just picked out like the
farm-to-table concept I know we're still
on that trend of everything's organic
and you know gosh we're there the spa
industry everything that's so bringing
yourself back to your senses we are in
such a stressful world we're on 24/7
even more so everybody needs to like
calm down and breathe a little bit and I
find that so often I will overlap with
the industries like that because they
might just literally have a 10 person
dinner party in the middle of some
farmer's field I mean you guys have
heard about all these like you know
private parties that happen like it just
it's a big industry hey and you know
being part of that doesn't have to be a
big scale may not be like a huge profit
maker but it's the awareness it's it's
people realizing that they sort of need
flowers in their lives
so yes local to anyone anywhere you've
been doing that you can do it we build
the events we do everything and anything
that you need to I think it's it doesn't
have to be your local florists I think
you want to go anywhere but I think you
should promote what's local but I I keep
an open mind when it comes to floristry
I find that so many people's think oh
well it's a formula I'm gonna do
whatever I literally shock the market to
see what's out there each week I do it
well people you know you have to do this
my customers call me and say well what
do you think you know here's my budget
what can I do that's amazing I you know
I'll dream it up and I'll say this is
what it is and I know that this is out
there and this is what we could do local
to anyone anywhere I can send flowers
you know outside
I can coordinate with somebody to do an
event you know anywhere in any state and
everything like that but it's a matter
of just knowing what's around and local
resources so you can be based in one
location but you know floral event party
people learn things you don't just have
to be in your little store with your
door.you sign open and close
we're just open to open ideas something
anybody dizzy is it seeds of the future
you know what depends on the trends you
know I I noticed speaking earlier about
like you know oh how do I get inspired
by all this stuff and I think I'm not
just inspired by what's out there
horticulturally I mean we know all the
planets there's not really that many new
plants that pop up I think that
sometimes you get a trend like a Martha
Stewart thing will come out and be like
oh you know now the hellebores are
amazing to use yes everybody exact
alibis rosemary in their wedding
bouquets you know I really started kind
of research you know I read magazines
constantly you know I'm online on blogs
and you know anything and everything
that I could do to just absorb trends I
love when my favorite things to do is
Fashion Week and I'm always like
watching I'm like going I just stay for
the runway shows does I want to see the
craziness that's out there and people
pushing barriers and listen just with
like Vogue magazine sometimes they've
got some crazy outfits that none of us
would ever wear but the take away is
like wow but what if we scaled that back
this is something that's maybe maybe the
thing is all black and white with very
sharp edges or stuff like that well
maybe that's a trend that's out there
that I can start using in flowers and
people may not realize it but maybe it's
a very trendy you know thing that we
have to do very chic wedding so the
wedding gown designers will probably you
know follow that trend so why wouldn't
your flowers sort of mimic your
personality which is your personality
that was the same person that bought the
dress that had the sharp line so it all
ties it together but what do statistics
I noticed since weddings are the
predominance of my business know any of
you are married or you know how much you
actually spend money this is like a
national average
roughly about 33,000 for a wedding I
honestly think that's a little low but
I'm also closer to Manhattan and stuff
so weddings tend to be a little bit more
where we are this one just has a couple
different things but I wanted to show
you so floral and decor now this one
again I feel this is it this is the
national average what people will spend
on flowers for a basic wedding I I tend
again I'm lured towards Manhattan so I'm
more on the higher end of what it is and
and I find you know so many magazines
promote and say it's 10% of your entire
wedding budget it really just depends
what people want to put their Forte on I
have had people and a lot of money on
events and decor mind you usually the
flowers are a good portion of it but
you're chopping all the rentals all the
tables the linens the lighting and
whatnot it can add up really quickly but
again the whole industry is like I think
it's a hundred and eight billion dollar
industry just a venture core you know
and you look at this and you say how
many weddings can you get in a year and
you know it's just very much I could
live off the fact of just doing events I
don't have to have a retail store I
personally have a retail store because I
have spin-offs so if I have extra
flowers from an event you know sometimes
you only need 24 roses but you have gift
by 25 or you know it's it's always those
one-offs and stuff like that they're
still very viable to sell then you have
that is extra and it's profit on top of
what you're doing so if you've been
cover your cost with everything that you
have you know why not have a little
retail on it but I find that you know
seriously the the event decor
industry is just huge a there's a it's a
wonderful industry that's really my
presentation and I wanted to open it up
for some questions because I know it's
it covers a lot of different things so
thank you very much actually
[Laughter]
yes what trends in individual flowers
types of flowers are you noticing that
people are tending towards in their
weddings like more rural you know wild
flowers or all the Victorian flower yeah
yeah I mean it sort of depends on your
personality they're still very much a
trend to be a little bit more
farm-to-table concept so they would
rather have those somewhat imperfection
dahlias that were grown in grandma's
yard kind of look rather than the
mass-produced spider mom and carnation
ball of an arrangement so something
that's very true to what it is kind of
flower color wise it's all over the
board but something that's just
naturally grown sustainably grown
organically grown if they know the story
of where it comes from like I'm all over
that
you know herbs are very popular there's
a lot of meaning and it's farm-to-table
it's entertaining your senses yes
succulents into your of course I have
yes that is a huge trend in all honesty
I'm actually sort of sick of them we
have done more than our fair share of
you know little echeverria boutonnieres
and whatnot but they're still very much
out there they're well-loved they're
great little place card holders so we
use them all the time second question do
you have to do any work out in the
Hamptons
RINO's fishes can use them do you is
there any movement by the people
planning the parties to communicate
their guests where these flowers came
from or what the inspiration was like
verbally or in place cards yeah yeah and
that's absolutely a great selling point
to people they love to know work
everybody wants to know where the
money's being spent and you know
sometimes there's meaning a lot of times
full put out like little seed packets as
there favors you know
seeds of forget-me-nots because you're
getting me knots don't forget my
grandmother that passed away and there's
things like that there's always a lot of
meaning and stuff like that yes focusing
on weddings a lot
how much do weddings dominate your
business and we're just horrible
industry and what you do personally I
would say about 80% of my business is
weddings I definitely do a lot of
corporate events I do private party type
things that are just I'm not so much in
the apartments for the bat mitzvah
industry
I think everybody's different you know
it depends what you again the sort of
kind of is a little bit of a location
like if in your town you you tend to
have a higher Jewish community you might
be more into that stuff but where I am
I'm fortunate enough that there's a lot
of wedding venues and a lot of brides
like my style so Iran of it majority of
my visitors what do you guys do with
like the trimmings on organic yeah we do
the best we can to be spread about it
you know we I do have a little somewhat
compostable area in the back of my store
that when we can but it's hard because I
don't always know what's been on the
flowers so the reason why I don't saw my
flowers as edible flowers because I
didn't I don't always know it was
straight for something it's up there
when it comes to waste of an event you
know I'm always encouraging brides and
whatever to you know have their guests
here so whether it's a small little
arrangement so those are easy to walk
away please encourage that take that
away or if it's a larger arrangement I
just need the babies back because that's
a rental piece take the plate with the
flowers and enjoy it what they do with
it from there I'm not sure I know if
somebody was asking me about bringing it
to you know like like homes and and
donating your flowers afterwards I can
do that I have done that for certain
people but you just have to think about
it logically there's a little bit of
expense that
with that for me to do it but I know if
there's companies that will do that
even just reaching out to some of these
charities so gladly come get in the room
take some extra flowers for me I'm happy
to spread that well enjoy it do it can
you describe one of the biggest wildest
event you ever guys Wow yeah it's a
wildest there's been a bunch I think
most recently I you know we were at the
Plaza for a big 4,000 person dinner oh I
got a holiday party and you know hanging
things up 16 feet in the air and saying
geez I better go buy that 12 foot ladder
because I'll never get it done if I
don't
and oh gosh I don't know it depends I
mean those aren't those are fun things
I've had I was telling somebody about
the story earlier today like the horror
stories of dealing with huge weddings
and having everything right and the
pressures on to get just right but I had
a bride who thought hot pink is it the
same as fuchsia but she was so
distraught that I got the wrong color
hot pink that she cancelled her
honeymoon early and came back and asked
for a refund not many bad stories but
yeah random stories I've had a lot of
celebrity stories of decorating himself
and one way I want to say favorites I
was telling somebody about the Whitney
Houston you know she lived in Mendham
were close to one store and then doing
the funerals and having my husband be
the extra delivery guy that day and you
know hiding the the cards that were from
the Jackson family or I'm Elton John
like don't look at this this is private
this is personal because you know it's
very interesting and the relationship I
mean these are my customers these are
people that are near and dear to me I'm
writing their direct sentiments on cards
and in conveying their sentiments and
flowers and it isn't anybody's business
I think you know I get very protective
of it and and they're people just like
you and I these friends you know
well you know I think the industry trade
magazines are like the florists from
your magazine sometimes don't have you
know you come in and say oh we just
found how we can ship our peonies from
from Alaska that was a bright I had last
year insisted she needed a peony in
August in New Jersey and I'm I don't
think are you doing this but you know
what let's just think outside of the box
well who could grow that I know when I
mean offseason I'll get them from New
Zealand but they're four times the cost
of what they should be but listen
somebody the last two figured out that
they could extend their season you just
think about where they are they can and
why not so it's really the shipping
costs so I knew it was more expensive
than your normal next-door neighbor who
has bees are there but if need be for
certain flowers you can and IIb you just
keep your ear to the ground I go to the
market every so often to talk to
wholesalers market New York City yeah I
also I mean even my local grower
wholesalers in New Jersey you know even
the ones that are had like their trucks
and they just go around from farm to
farm and you listen listen to what's
going on and how do you adapt to it and
do you know somebody who's trying this
um you know you you want to be ahead of
the curve so you don't want to have a
flop either Lee you know I had one
player in spring cafe au lait values for
me and you know they just didn't realize
how much time it would take for each one
and now you understand when I pay for
them there you know sometimes three
dollars and fifty cents ahead my cost
you know and they didn't realize I mean
the production the awareness wasn't out
there so then plays into the whole
education of letting your customers know
the amazing stuff that can be had that's
out there and then maybe the cost of
look how snowballs together this
there's always
issues.i I don't feel in my heart of
hearts that most florists practice the
best ways to go about it I mean there's
so much that plays into the cost of it
efficiency I mean we're all here we have
to you know pay staff and do everything
and you got to get the job done and
everything so you know I think I would
love to learn better ways and I would
love to spread that word and educate
even my fellow florists and and
everything to maybe get it to be a
standard I think there's such a love of
it amongst the general population
especially like younger generations that
want that that will probably pay for
that and then so if I know and I tell my
friends hey let's all practices that's
you know really are you even just
separating your garbage are you doing
that and then I don't know but they
could because it's something that
would you say that it's also raise
expectations like an artistic ribbon
that matches yours yeah but I love the
challenge so I I encourage that I
encourage actually seeing perhaps a full
Pinterest board so I want them to show
me what do they pick up your shoes and
their earrings and what is their dress
you wouldn't and I look at the whole
thing and I guess need the experience of
being around for this long to know what
could be out there like maybe they've
never even entertained using maidenhair
furnace little accent you know they're
fern but it so reflects the lace that
they have on their dress I love doing
that it can be challenging you know I
know that the trends are out there I
think we're find the most frustration is
when it comes down to the budget because
again let you open up any kind of
beautiful wedding magazine like I want
that you know bridging the two tactfully
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu